RIGHT NOW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE,"
HAPPY FRIDAY.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IT TURNS
OUT THAT REVOLUTIONS COVER A
MULTITUDE OF SINS.
ONCE EVERY CONVERSATION IN YOUR
COUNTRY TURNS POLITICAL, ONLY
THE POLITICIANS BENEFIT FROM IT.
IN A NORMAL MOMENT, THE PEOPLE
IN CHARGE WILL BE IN DEEP
TROUBLE RIGHT NOW.
THE REST OF US MIGHT BE ASKING
THE HARD QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY
THINGS SEEM TO BE FALLING APART
AT THE MOST BASIC LEVEL.
WHY OUR STREETS ARE FILTHY, WHY
VIOLENT CRIME IS RISING AND WHY
NOTHING SEEMS TO WORK.
WE PAY A LOT TO KEEP SOCIETY
FUNCTIONING, ALL OF US OF ALL
PARTIES AND SUDDENLY WE ARE NOT
GETTING A LOT IN RETURN FOR
THAT.
IT’S NOT A VERY GOOD DEAL.
BUT IN THE AGE OF PLM, OUR
LEADERS DON’T HAVE TO ANSWER FOR
THIS.
THEY JUST GIVE SPEECHES ABOUT
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
THEY ARE INSULATED FROM ALL
CRITICISM.
IF YOU BOTHER THEM BUT THEIR
INCOMPETENCE, THEY WILL HAVE YOU
ARRESTED FOR HATE CRIMES.
REVOLUTION IS THE BEST THING
THAT HAPPENED TO OUR POLITICAL
CLASS.
YOU SEE IT WITH PERFECT CLARITY
IN NEW YORK CITY.
A FEW MONTHS AGO
BILL de BLASIO WAS A NATIONAL
JOKE, NOT ANYMORE.
NOW de BLASIO IS HIS
GENERATION’S AL SHARPTON.
HE IS A PROTEST LEADER FIGHTING
IN THE STREETS FOR CIVIL RIGHTS.
HE NO LONGER HAS TO PRETEND TO
RUN NEW YORK CITY.
HE’S NOT.
HIS PUBLIC SCHOOLS FOR EXAMPLE
ARE FAILING.
IN NEW YORK WHICH IS THE BIGGEST
SCHOOL SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY,
FEWER THAN HALF STUDENTS ARE
PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH AND MATH.
THAT IS A DISASTER MOST OF ALL
FOR THE STUDENTS THEMSELVES.
WHY IS THAT HAPPENING?
WHY ARE THE SCHOOLS FAILING?
CITY OFFICIALS DON’T WANT TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION.
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THERE IS A
MASSIVE PROBLEM MIGHT REQUIRE
THEM TO DO SOMETHING A TO FIX
IT.
THEIR DONORS AND THE TEACHERS
UNIONS OPPOSE CHANGE OF ANY KIND
UNLESS OF COURSE IT’S A RAVE.
LEADERS IN YORKTOWN HAVE TO
ADDRESS IT.
THEY CAN IGNORE FAILING SCHOOLS.
INSTEAD OF HELPING KIDS LEARN,
THE CITY CAN BLAME RACISM AND
CALL IT A DAY.
IT MAY SEEM LIKE A WEIRD
STRATEGY, STRANGE EXPLANATION IN
NEW YORK, RACISM.
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL POPULATION
NEW YORK IS 84% NONWHITE.
NOT THAT MANY WHITE KIDS TO
BLAME.
BUT THAT’S NOT STOP THE
CHANCELLOR OF THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
HE RECENTLY SHOULD A STATEMENT
PLEDGING HIS COMMITMENT TO
ANTIRACISM INTO "WORK EVERY DAY"
TO UNDO THE SYSTEMS OF
INJUSTICE.
YOU NOTICE THE CHANCELLOR WAS
NOT MORE SPECIFIC THAN THAT.
HE DIDN’T SPECIFY WITH SYSTEMS
OF INJUSTICE HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT HOW THEY WORK.
MAYBE THAT’S BECAUSE THE KIDS
THE HIGHEST TEST SCORES IN
NEW YORK CITY ARE NOT WHITE.
THEY ARE ASIAN.
ASIAN STUDENTS WHO ARE FAR
HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER ETHNIC
GROUP IN NEW YORK CITY.
NOT JUST HIGHER SCORES IN MATH
BUT ALSO SCORES IN HIS
PROFICIENCY.
THAT SEEMS ODD.
SO MANY OF THESE STUDENTS COME
FROM POOR IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
WHERE NO ONE AT HOME SPEAKS
ENGLISH.
SO AT FIRST GLANCE, THESE KIDS
DON’T SEEM TO HAVE MUCH
PRIVILEGE.
SO HOW ARE THEY SO SUCCESSFUL?
WELL, RACISM, OBVIOUSLY.
NO OTHER POSSIBLE EXPLANATION
FOR DISTRICT TEST SCORES.
WE ARE TOLD THAT EVERY DAY.
MUST BE A STEALTHY KIND OF
RACISM THEY ARE PRACTICING.
INDEED, THIS IS AN ESPECIALLY
DIABOLICAL STRAIN OF RACISM.
WHILE THAT HELPS NONWHITE
IMMIGRANT KIDS MOST OF ALL.
IT’S A "SYSTEM OF INJUSTICE THAT
ALLOWS PANELIST FOREIGNERS FROM
FARAWAY COUNTRIES TO ARRIVE
HERE WITH NO LANGUAGE SKILLS
WHATSOEVER AND STILL SHOOT TO TH
TOP.
OBVIOUSLY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WHAT WE ARE DEALING WITH HERE IS
SYSTEMIC RACISM AT ITS MOST
SYSTEMIC.
THE MAYOR’S WIFE IS IN CHARGE OF
FIXING PROBLEMS LIKE THIS.
MRS. de BLASIO WAS THE CITIES
SYSTEMIC RACISM STAR BUT IN THE
END, SHE WAS ANY MORE SPECIFIC
ABOUT THE PROBLEM IN THE
CHANCELLOR OF SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN.
SHE DIDN’T EXPLAIN HOW THIS KIND
OF DIABOLICAL RACISM ACTUALLY
WORKS.
WHAT SHE DID SAY, THE ONE INC.
SHE WAS ACTUALLY CONFIDENT ABOUT
IS THAT WHY PEOPLE ARE TO BLAME.
>> EVEN IN 2020, TO BE A PERSON
OF COLOR MEANS TO LIVE A
PARALLEL EXISTENCE WITH WHITE
NEW YORKERS.
THAT REALITY NEEDS TO BE
UNDERSTOOD THE OWN COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR.
THAT TRUTH MUST INFORM THE
CURRICULA IN OUR SCHOOLS, OUR
HISTORY BOOKS, THE MEMORIALS WE
HONOR, AND EVEN HOW WE PERCEIVE
ONE ANOTHER.
>> Tucker: OH.
SO THE ASIAN KIDS ARE DOING
BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE IN
SCHOOL, THEREFORE WE MUST TEAR
DOWN STATUES OF WHITE PEOPLE.
GOT IT.
MAKES SENSE.
SUDDENLY THIS KIND OF THINKING
IS EVERYWHERE.
HERE’S A TAPE FROM A MEETING OF
THE COMMUNITY EDUCATION COUNCIL
IN MANHATTAN.
THE SAD PART IS THESE ARE SOME
OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPPOSED
TO HELP EDUCATE THE CHILDREN OF
NEW YORK CITY, WHO BADLY NEED
EDUCATION.
SEE MANY REFERENCES YOU CATCH AS
YOU WATCH THIS TO READING OR
MATH.
COMPARE THEM TO THE TIME THESE
PEOPLE SPEND ATTACKING EACH
OTHER FOR BEING TOO WHITE.
>> IT HURTS PEOPLE WHEN THEY SEE
A WHITE MAN BOUNCING A BROWN
BABY ON THEIR LAP AND THEY DON’T
KNOW THE CONTEXT.
IT’S HARMFUL!
IT MAKES PEOPLE CRY.
I TAKE THAT TO HEART AND THAT
HURTS ME, AND I FOR ONE WANT TO
BE A BETTER WHITE PERSON.
YOU DON’T HAVE PEOPLE TELL YOU
THAT.
>> WOULD LIKE TO KNOW BEFORE
THIS MEETING ADJOURNS HOW HAVING
MY FRIENDS NEPHEW ON MY LAP WAS
HURTFUL TO PEOPLE AND WAS
RACIST.
CAN USE YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN?
>> I JUST EXPLAINED IT.
YOU CAN GOOGLE.
READ A BOOK.
READ "WHITE FRAGILITY," READ --
IT’S NOT MY JOB TO EDUCATE YOU!
>> Tucker: THAT IS THE
EDUCATION COUNCIL.
THE STUDENTS OF NEW YORK CITY,
84% NONWHITE, MOST CAN READ
PROFICIENTLY.
WHAT A TRAGEDY.
BUT IT IS TRUE, THEY DID TALK
ABOUT READING FOR SECOND IN THE
TAPE YOU JUST TOLERATED THE END.
THEY WOULD LIKE YOU TO READ
SOMETHING CALLED "WHITE
FRAGILITY" BY ROBYN D’ANGELO.
IT’S NOT REALLY A BOOK.
IT’S WHAT WOULD CALL A TRACT,
SCREED, DIATRIBE, A WILD HIDE
HATE PROPAGANDA YOU PUSH BEFORE
YOU START TO REALLY START
HURTING PEOPLE.
IT’S PREEMPTIVE JUSTIFICATION
FOR ABUSE.
HERE IS THE AUTHOR EXPLAINING
HER THESIS ON NBC.
>> I’LL NEVER FORGET ASKING A
GROUP, OKAY, SO WHAT IF YOU
COULD JUST GIVE US FEEDBACK ON
OUR INEVITABLE AND UNAWARE
RACIST ASSUMPTIONS AND BEHAVIORS
THEY WILL NEVER FORGET THIS
BLACK MAN RAISING HIS HAND AND
SAYING, IT WOULD BE
REVOLUTIONARY.
REVOLUTIONARY THAT WE WOULD
RECEIVE THE FEEDBACK WITH GRACE,
REFLECT, AND SEEK THE CHANGE OR
BEHAVIOR.
THAT’S HOW DIFFICULT WE ARE.
THAT’S HOW BIG A A-HOLES WE ARE.
>> Tucker: WHITE PEOPLE ARE
A-HOLES.
THERE YOU HAVE THE KEY RELATED
SCHOLARSHIP OF MS. ROBIN
D’ANGELO.
ROBIN D’ANGELO, KEEP IN MIND, IS
PROBABLY DISSING THE MOST
POPULAR FIGURE IN AMERICAN
EDUCATION RIGHT NOW.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AROUND THE
COUNTRY HAVE MADE WHITE
FRAGILITY REQUIRED READING.
YOUR CHILDREN WILL ALMOST REALLY
READ IT OR BE TAUGHT BY PEOPLE
WHO READ IT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IT MEANS THAT SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
CLOSE FOR MONTHS NOW SO THE
REVOLUTION UNDERWAY IN
CLASSROOMS HAS BEEN HIDDEN FOR